a giant asteroid is heading our way
but no it won't hit the earth
this asteroid is about to slam into the
moon and crack it right in half
what would it be like to witness this
epic collision
would the moon break clean in two
or would it shatter into a million
pieces
and how could one of those pieces wipe
out life here on earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if an asteroid cracked the moon
in half
before getting into our scenario let me
tell you about the time long ago when
the moon almost exploded
it was a beautiful summer night in
england in the year 1178
and one hour after sunset people
witnessed a spectacular phenomenon
a giant flame appeared around the upper
part of that evening's crescent moon
and right before their eyes the moon
appeared to split in two before turning
black
at least this is how the event was
recorded by the local chronicler
as you could probably guess the moon
didn't actually split in half that night
it's possible that what these people saw
was a large asteroid slamming into it
but an event like this would have sent
massive amounts of lunar material toward
earth
more likely what they witnessed was a
meteorite entering the atmosphere and
crossing their line of sight directly in
front of the moon
this would have given the illusion of it
splitting in two in a fiery fashion
but who needs illusions or questionable
historical accounts when we could
imagine what would really happen
just get ready to avoid falling moon
rocks
this would be a one in a million
experience that you could pass on but
with omaze you have the chance to win an
experience of a lifetime yeah i'm
excited to be working with omaze to
offer you the chance to win a super
performance mark 3r while supporting a
great cause the peterson automotive
museum check out omaze.com
what if to enter for your chance to win
i can feel that horsepower right through
the screen your entries will support
this non-profit that provides on-site
and online education for under-served
communities automotive research and so
much more in just a few clicks you can
support this fantastic cause and enter
these sweepstakes for a chance to win
this iconic muscle car imagine cruising
down the road in this beauty so for your
chance to win a super performance mark
3r go to omaze.com
what if and enter now
donations support the amazing work of
the peterson automotive museum you know
with this car you might even have a
chance to outrun anything falling from
the sky
the moon is bombarded by hundreds of
asteroids and meteorites every year
and without an atmosphere like we enjoy
back on earth
these objects don't burn up before
impact
so even a meteorite as small as 25
centimeters across could have a big
impact on the moon
in 2006 one approximately this size
slammed into it
from earth the impact looked like a
flash that lasted only four tenths of a
second
but it created a crater about 14 meters
long and three meters deep
taking things up a notch a 40 centimeter
meteoroid slammed into the moon at a
speed of 90
100 kilometers per hour this was such an
intense collision that it caused a flash
as bright as some of the stars in the
night sky
that means when this happened in 2013
you could look up and see the events
unfolding without a telescope
for one whole second at least
the likeliest contender within our solar
system of doing some serious damage to
the moon would be ceres
it's the largest object found in the
belt between jupiter and mars
while it's technically classified as a
dwarf planet it's still only about a
quarter as large as the moon
but even that wouldn't be enough to
break the moon in two
or at least to knock it out of its orbit
for that you'd need an asteroid almost
the same size as the moon itself
and if this happened
you'd know it right away
about 1.3 seconds after impact you'd see
the moon being torn apart
massive amounts of debris would be
hurtling toward earth
some of this debris could be even larger
than the asteroid that caused the mass
extinction of the dinosaurs
but before you start picturing the life
on earth wiped out scenario
things might not be as bad as you think
normally earthbound asteroids travel at
speeds faster than 100 kilometers per
second
but it would be different for the chunks
of the broken moon and the moon
destroying asteroid
these would have much lower speeds and
with that much less energetic impacts
if you were lucky
the impact from even the most colossal
pieces of lunar debris would release
only one percent of the energy of a
similar sized asteroid
adding to your luck you'd get to witness
a meteor shower of truly epic
proportions as smaller bits of debris
would burn up in the atmosphere
and this epic collision wouldn't result
in two split halves of the moon now
orbiting around earth
sadly you'd have to kiss the moon
goodbye
it would be shattered into a million
pieces
but if it were to somehow break more or
less in two
there would be a chance you wouldn't
even know
at least not right away
that's because the asteroid could have
split the moon right between the side
that always faces earth and its dark
side
you could still see the front of the
moon beaming down on you
eventually the two halves could escape
each other's gravity revealing two
hemispheres in the night sky and they'd
stay like that for a long time
at least until the effects of gravity
pulling each half from all sides shape
them into similar spheres
but that would take millions if not
billions of years
if the moon is blown to bits our night
sky would be permanently transformed
into a dazzling sea of stars
venus would become the new brightest
object despite the fact that it's 14 000
times less bright than the moon once was
some of the more drastic consequences of
the moon being destroyed would start to
make your life difficult
the moon is responsible for the earth's
23.4 degree tilt on its axis
without it this tilt could become as
much as 45 degrees
that would make our planet spin nearly
on its side and this would mean the sun
would no longer shine directly over the
equator
instead it would beam down closer to the
north and south poles
this would trigger some extreme weather
and could lead to ice ages that occur on
different parts of the planet as often
as every few thousand years
and the tides would never be the same
again
earth's powerful tides are caused by the
moon's gravitational pull on our oceans
the sun's gravitational pull on our sea
levels is only about half of what the
moon can pull off
no longer having the moon in our orbit
would lower sea levels and have a huge
effect on ecosystems in intertidal zones
tidal wetlands species would now have
even more fierce competition for food
and shelter
this could really endanger a lot of
marine life like sea turtles
the rising and falling of tides is an
extremely important factor in giving
their offspring the best chance of
survival
still this would all be a lot better
than if the earth took a direct hit from
an asteroid nearly the size of the moon
but
that's a story
for
another what if